hello everybody i am back here with
richard rowland uh one more episode of
our universal history series which has
been really bringing up so many positive
comments people are excited about it so
it's fun for us because we are so
excited about universal history that
we're both surprised and overjoyed to
see that people uh are following us down
this rabbit hole and so today is going
to be our last episode on ethiopia i
know it's we've been talking about
ethiopia a lot but it is so relevant to
the situation of kind of the beginning
and the end joining together and all
this kind of eschatological vision and
so today we're going to look at
ethiopian several ethiopian practices
and how they kind of manifest
the two aspects of ethiopia one which is
this idea of the container or the ark
and then the other aspect is the idea of
the edge and the extreme and how all
these kind of traditions come together
to uh to manifest a very specific and
particular
particular version of orthodox
christianity so richard i hope you're
ready for this because i'm excited
[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
i am i'm also excited and yes i'm ready
i've been reading i think i told you
this
i've been i've been working my way
through like an 800 page
ethiopian
uh the their cinexarium their
geographical text i haven't made it
quite all the way through this week but
i've read i've read just a lot of
pagiography and it's all sort of
bouncing around on my head so i'm i'm
ready
all right and we're deeply confident
i'll let you throw the ball in there and
start the conversation and and we'll
we'll go along on it yeah you discovered
i think you're probably the only person
in the world that i know
that has read uh
like i know about the nine saints but
i've never heard of this more extensive
kind of uh hagiography ethiopian
hagiography yeah well they have a uh
in in the orthodox church we call it the
cinexarion um and i think the word that
they use from the coptic tradition is
the cenexaryum but it's the same same
word same thing right which is basically
just like the daily commemorations the
the daily lives of the saints um and so
they have they have a book like that uh
very much like we do uh maybe equivalent
to like the the western like the roman
martyrology or something like that
um although i don't fully i would just
confess like i don't fully understand
how uh
how
like that book that set of liturgical
books actually works in in the latin
tradition so you know please don't add
me or actually at me and and tell me why
i'm wrong but anyway
so
um
what i wanted to start with the reason
i'm talking about hagiography um other
than the fact that it's just something
i'm deeply interested in and it's one of
the main let's say source materials for
legendary history or universal history
um and uh certainly the most popular
genre of literature in the middle ages
last time we talked and we kind of ended
on this note uh in our in our previous
video that this uh about the the fact
that the saints uphold the world
now i believe that to be literally true
um it's like you know i do believe that
there are people right now in this world
praying for us that are that are holding
back the judgment of god that are
um you know and and that you know whose
prayers we're we're joining we're
participating in um
especially in the in the liturgy
but i also think that this
this saying the saints uphold the world
provides a very important interpretive
key
or symbolic key for understanding the
way that a given principality manifests
itself
so something we talked about i think it
was last time
is is this idea that the way that the
thing the thing that sort of
symbolically ties stuff together is
always going to be a person
um it's like you've got everything in
the cosmos sort of moving towards
personhood
and you have uh and and you have so you
have
the way that a
the way that a principality manifests
itself that it's going to be most
strongly tied together is going to be in
in a person usually in some kind of a a
cult a cultus of veneration and i don't
mean like guys with dark hoods around
pentagrams like cult in the like the
anthropological sense people um where
where cultures you know which is a latin
word that means you know worship or
veneration um
it's that's the that's the root of our
word culture right so the way that you
have a culture is that you have you have
a culture of a veneration around a
common point and the common point is
usually a person yeah and it's really
important because we we have a kind of
neopl we have a kind of platonic
under you know strata in our
understanding and we tend to think of
ideas or these abstract principles as
being the thing which binds us together
uh but in reality in terms of human
human reality things are actually bound
together by people you know remembering
and celebrating our common ancestors our
heroes our politicians our saints this
is actually the man in which we
recognize
unity much more than
you know the idea of liberty or freedom
or this these kind of revolutionary
abstract idea ideals we we remember
napoleon and you know the french
remember napoleon and unite themselves
under napoleon much more than you know
fraternity equality you know and freedom
whatever in english you say it however
you say it yeah and and to talk about
that period for a moment you know
because you had the american revolution
the french revolution all happening
right there at the same time and one of
the things that they would do especially
in the iconography of that time and you
know over the same course of maybe the
next 50 years as they start building
buildings and painting murals and things
like this is that they do really try to
to
uh depict
the
like the let's say the genius of a
particular country you know uh
liberty equality fraternity or or uh uh
victory was a really important one um at
that period
uh
and then you know like colombia as this
you know in the new world like colombia
as the uh as like the goddess of the new
world and there's a lot of art
especially like in a if you go to like
the united states capitol building or
some of our other
um
um
yeah shrines yeah i was trying to think
of a word that wasn't that but that's
the right word um if you go there you'll
see you'll see these figures depicted
you know these female figures often like
nude or semi nude you know depicted in
the same way as as greco-roman uh
uh greco-roman gods and the interesting
thing is that um
this was this was a conscious attempt
to tie back to greco-roman civilization
and personify these things these
abstract ideas
as gods and goddesses and the
interesting thing is that it did not
work
nobody in the popular imagination like
in the popular imagination
if you said
what's the personification of america
most people who instantly go to george
washington yeah
you know like most most people most of
the time and i'm not trying to make like
it's it's stupid that you know like like
there's a whole political thing right
now about whether or not that's a good
thing but i'm not trying to make a
statement about that i'm just saying
like most people most of the time if i
show you george washington's pick your
picture on a one dollar bill
like that's that's the most
that's the most uh immediately
recognizable icon so the interesting
thing is that is that we tried to create
these symbols artificially and that did
not work yeah the exception i would say
lady liberty like the statue of liberty
because it's so big yes i think that
that right it was able to kind of
imprint itself on on the imagination and
act as almost like a
like a kind of goddess figure for
america that's as close as you get yeah
but it is it is not the it's not the
rule it really is the only one all the
other figures are our people right if i
showed most people uh like a picture of
the the goddess victory you know nike
you know and was like who's this people
don't know even though she's on the the
the ceiling of the rotunda at the u.s
capitol building
so um
so this is so this this is all to say
um
the symbolism of a nation with a symbol
being understood as something that holds
two realities together
rests most fully in its saints
and uh that includes those nations which
are not overtly christian like the
united states uh for instance but which
still have what a mulch and what amounts
to a cult of veneration and a hagia uh
hagiographical tradition and i'm just
gonna say a quick thing again about like
uh abraham lincoln because that got a
lot of people very excited or very salty
last time
uh it's funny because i saw you know the
clip and i'm sure you're too seasoned of
a youtuber to go and like read the
comments on your own videos but i went
down and looked at the comments on the
clip of the stuff that we were saying
about lincoln and one guy was like oh
typical americans you know they're
they're they're only focused on you know
what happens to their own country and i
was like dude this is from a video about
ethiopia like come on come on
pedro's canadian come on but anyway um
but but uh
the
i just want to i just want to like
i want to give an easy example since
most of our viewers are americans so we
can understand that actually we do this
and then we'll go and we'll talk about
ethiopia so uh so this is gonna this
this idea of a cult of veneration
um
a hagiographical tradition this includes
both biography but it also includes
legendary material right george
washington chopping down his father's
cherry tree or the legend of honest abe
are just as important
maybe more so than anything either of
those men did which is historically
verifiable
um
that's super important to understand
because it participates not only in the
identity of george washington but like
you said that legend as its frame
becomes a kind of a frame for how
americans perceive themselves right
right we're honest we're forthright we
sort of you know uh
the the way that we want to think about
ourselves
whether or not we live up to this right
the way that we want to think about
ourselves is that we're honest we're
forthright we sort of do the right thing
no matter what the cost is right um so
when lincoln died his body was
moved or you could say his relics were
translated
across the country
uh to be to be buried i think in
springfield um and uh there was at every
stop along the way there people came
on pilgrimage to see and to venerate his
his body this is very religious thing
when his body reached um
uh you know the the
there they're in uh now where he's
buried in illinois i think it's illinois
um
i i've actually been there a couple of
times but i was i was pretty young so my
family went on
essentially a pilgrimage to the tomb of
abraham lincoln my dad it was really
into lincoln uh when i was a kid i read
this massive multi-volume biography of
lincoln's life
um and that was one of the things that
was you know like i was encouraged to
read as a young person um and and like
and i want to make it clear like i'm not
really down on lincoln or you know i and
a certain part of me like i don't feel
like this is necessarily like a huge
problem this is just the way that this
is the way that america is like if you
want you got to understand like this is
part of our our identity
um but so this is you'll just get a kick
out of this okay um so there at
uh at lincoln's tube there's a large uh
copper as in the penny bust so i don't
i'm i'm just assuming you know things
about american money so lincoln is on
that one is on our penny our one cent
piece right he's on our penny
um uh we have debt presidents on all of
our money lincoln's on the penny and
he's on the five dollar bill
and um and so there's a a massive copper
bust
made
of lincoln's head
and the whole thing is tarnished except
for the nose and the nose is bright and
shiny why because people rub it because
as you enter the tomb of lincoln you are
supposed to reach up and rub the nose
wow
for good luck yeah it reminds me of that
statue of saint peter at the vatican
there's a statue of saint peter where
his foot is almost completely worn down
because people walk in and everybody
rubs the foot yes so so it's like it's
like you're here's a here's a statue of
lincoln i'm going to venerate it for a
blessing and then i'm going to enter his
tomb right so
um
that i think it's mostly to understand
like you said right we're not we're
neither criticizing or celebrating this
we're just saying that this is how it
works exactly this is actually how
how any identity kind of holds together
through these act of celebrating and
venerating and remembering the the those
that that were that marks our history
marked our story and also participated
in our unity so so this is just how it
works and so it can help americans
understand like you said why
religious practices look the way they do
because they're they're not just they're
more than religious in a strict sense
they're just the way that reality
reality lays itself out to quote my my
friend jonathan pajot it's not arbitrary
no it's not i'm sorry
this idea like of having even the
picture of the president in all official
buildings like they i don't know if they
do it but i know they did it uh they did
it before you know this kind of idea of
having the image of the emperor the
image of the king or the image you know
in all these public spaces to mark his
presence and as you enter you kind of
see who the principality is that's at
this moment holding all this together is
something which is
which is very religious and it's uh
in the way i once i once organized a uh
an event at a protestant very like
reformed baptist protestant seminary
and uh when you get there outside the
building that we're in they have this
this this area called martyrs walk
and you walk along and it's got the
names of all of the uh you know these
different
baptist missionaries who have been
killed
doing overseas missions but then you go
inside
and uh you go inside and the the main
auditorium there
is wall to wall with the pictures of
each president and dean that the
seminary has ever had in its you know
history
and so it's you you walk in you know
there's like names of the martyrs along
the outside you go in and the room is
full of icons i was i was i was with a a
friend i was an orthodox at the time but
i was with a friend who was
and uh i
he and i just sort of looked at each
other and grinned a little bit and he
said and they say protestants don't have
icons
um
anyway and again like like my point is
i'm not trying to keep any kind of
criticism on anyone about this i'm just
trying to say like this is this is the
way that things cohere this is the way
that things hold together
so with with that being said
uh the best
way that we can understand the symbolism
of ethiopia i think is by reading
the lies of the ethiopian saints
and if we do eventually i know a lot of
people want to do like
ireland and celtic stuff
and if we do that then then we'll we'll
eventually do the same thing there
because
when we do this
we're going to see and notice certain
patterns which are going to manifest
themselves over and over again in
ethiopian hagiography
and like if you read a a large amount of
ethiopian hagiography what you're going
to see is a lot of the stuff is exactly
what you would expect from from any
christian hagiography pretty much
anywhere right it's the same religion
yeah
same jesus
you know holiness is not radically
different in ethiopia than it is other
places but then if you're attentive
you'll also notice that there are
certain things certain patterns
which might be present other places in
very small amounts yeah but which are
central
to the ethiopian experience of holiness
so that's what i want to start uh start
out by looking at today all right so the
first one of these which should be
surprising to absolutely no one is the
prominence of the idea of the ferta
sakura the ferta sacra which means the
the holy theft or the theft of the
sacred right
so the story usually goes something like
this you have a holy man who dies before
he dies he leaves instructions to his
disciples that he's supposed to be
buried in a certain place
and then for whatever reason often
because there's a ruler who has other
plans in mind his orders are not
followed because they're not followed
various calamities ensue
until someone steals the body
and buries it in the appropriate place
and then the calamities stop so the idea
is the saint is was actually willing you
know desired the stuff to take place in
some cases what they actually do is they
they put an empty they they they make a
replica coffin and they switch them and
they leave the empty coffin in place of
their original and they they they take
the original and they they bury it
wherever the saint wanted it buried
sometimes there's a trick in in the in
the translation yeah yes yeah yeah
um you know and that's i mean it's
obviously most people will right away
see that this is just a a kind of
playing out of the original right taking
of the arc and then now it's it's as if
like you when your foundational pattern
has a certain form then if you fractally
play itself out through your society
like it it's inevitable because that's
what you're looking at as your model and
as your first memory you could say and
then it just plays itself out through
through through the history so it's very
fascinating and you do you do find this
other sort of thing you know i've never
encountered it i've been reading
a really massive collection of welsh
hagiography recently like this is just
like if you could see my desk right now
there are just
stacks of printed out pages because none
of this stuff is published but you can
still find it online
um um i i actually got a new book of oh
yeah right here i just i just got a new
book of of uh of
the irish things irish hagiography
volume eight
uh the volume two this one's one two
sorry yeah i ate there yeah there's a
lot though there's a lot yeah there's a
lot a lot of these saints are really
wonderful nobody's heard of them
um but anyway
uh so
so
i've never encountered the fur to sakura
thing in in really almost any lives of
irish saints you do find it a little bit
in in byzantine hagiography
two examples that i can think of off the
top of my head there there might be a
couple of others though again it's not
very common one would be the translation
one of the translations of the relish of
saint nicholas which are stolen
but then because they're stolen uh
they're able to be saved from
the turks
just like a few days later
um and and so st nicholas appears in a
dream to basically tell
people listen
it's okay like this is this is how my
relics are being preserved um
another example and every year every
year like when we come across this and
we read this with our kids from the
saxarian
kids always ask me questions about it
because it seems so obviously wrong
um to their little minds uh and that is
the placing of the robe of the mother of
god at the at her church in black
carinae in constantinople do you know
the story no i don't uh so essentially
the story is that her her robe
um was
kept by one of her maidservants who was
not a christian was she was a jew
um after her death
uh i think this is commemorated in july
maybe on like july the 2nd but it might
be a little bit later in the month i
forget now
but um
and uh and so it's passed on from one
woman to another and they have this
tradition that the woman in the family
that holds it
has to be a she has to be a virgin and
so it comes to this woman who's like the
last one in the lineage there's no one
after her to take the the keeping of
this of this robe which even though
she's she's a jew she's not a christian
but like the the road works so many
miracles that people are always coming
to our house to be healed and all this
different stuff
and then one day uh these these two
byzantine nobles who were passing by
passing through
on their way back from a pilgrimage to
the holy land
like they're they they hear all these
miracles happening and so they go there
and
it's divinely revealed to them that this
is the robe of the mother of god
and uh and so they're they they sort of
like debate what do we do about this
what do we do about this and and
eventually and it sort of seems that
this there's like divine sanction for
what they do they make a replica coffer
like reliquary
and they switch them out
and they bring the robe to
constantinople and place it in the very
famous church of the mother of god at
placaroni so
that's a
that's a clear example of what you're
saying that's a crazy story and of
course it should be less crazy if we
understand the uh
the association of the mother of god
with the ark of the covenant right
but so that's that's a really clear
example of the the ferta sakura so that
that sort of thing is i would say rare
in byzantine hagiography at least
what from what i've read of it um
it's very common in the ethiopian high
geography i would say it's one of the
defining one of the defining patterns
um another one would be
and this is really interesting um
maybe something to mention and i'm not
sure that i like fully understand the
symbolic resonance here but one of the
interesting things that i've noticed is
that
in ethiopian hagiography the focus on
relics always tends to be on the whole
body
um whereas you know in like other
other christian cultures like relics
could be like a little piece or like a
hand you know like the left hand of mary
magdalene or the head of john the
baptist etc
um
but in in in ethiopian practice it
really does seem to be the whole body in
fact there's an example of one saying i
can't remember his name now but like at
some point his left leg just fell off
and
people they just sort of like tossed it
like it was very very strange like like
so it's like there's this focus on the
the whole body um and relics really mean
just the body not so for instance this
is to be con the contrast to this would
be in like the celtic tradition
where the relics of a saint can mean
their bones but they're just as likely
to mean things like
a bell or an altar or a vestment or
something like some holy object yeah
that belonged to the saint
um so it's it's a it's just kind of a
different approach
uh and then there's the something called
the kidan
and this is in
essentially every single
ethiopian hagiography that i've read at
the end there will be akiran and the
kidan
um
ethiopian people like i'm probably
saying the word wrong i actually i i
think i'm saying it right in this case
but uh but tell me if i'm if i'm not
um so the kidan is a is a pact between
the holy person and god that is made
before their death
and again there is very interestingly uh
something like this and um
saint maximus the confessor's i'm
looking to see if i have the book but
it's over there i say maximus the
confessor's life of the virgin
there's actually a moment like this like
right before her death she she asks
you know her son
that that he would honor her
intercessions uh for those who call upon
her name
right and so uh
but but but this sort of thing like this
sort of comment doesn't show up very
often in byzantine's saint line saints
lives but it's it's in every single
ethiopian saints life essentially and
basically it is what will happen
is that either christ himself or
sometimes the virgin mary or saint
michael the archangel will come to the
holy person shortly before their death
and make a promise
that god will answer the prayers and
come to the aid of those who observe the
saints memory
like the annual commemoration of the
saints life
um although some saints were actually
commemorated like monthly uh which is
apparently
uh i mean can you imagine
um yeah uh
and uh so you know one example says
whoever invokes your name whether inside
or outside
in a desert or wilderness
on every path
in his walking or his sitting in all of
his suffering i will heed his prayer and
demand immediately so this is this is
like a
it's a promise to reassure
the people who who venerate the saint
that their prayers are going to be heard
um so this is this is another one of the
really interesting um
one of the really interesting patterns
and if you think back to
all the stuff that's going on with uh
with uh solomon and his ethiopian son
you know you've got like the theft of
the ark but then also you know solomon
says well you stole the ark and nobody
died
so this must be from god so the idea is
that it's a theft
which is kind of an ambiguous thing but
then it's something that something that
god seemed to have willed
yeah and there's also there's also
something at least in the uh the image
of the theft of the ark there and even
in this image of the theft of the the
vestment of the mother of god of her
robe
there's something there is a pattern in
like that between identities you could
say that
sometimes
the
the relationship or the translation
between identities happens through
tricks because it's not within it's not
within
an identity and so you can see that
obviously in the story of jacob
quite often you know with
with laban and then you can also see it
with moses and the pharaoh there's all
these these stories especially the old
testament of when you're in the
stranger's land
sometimes the the interaction with the
stranger will happen through a kind of
trick yeah and so you see that uh in the
story and it's interesting that you
mentioned for example that
the the the taking one of the only
swords in the byzantine tradition is the
taking of the robe of the virgin and
that this is very much related to the
idea of the ark itself you know as this
container as this kind of outer shell
um
it's kind of outer feminine shell yeah
so it's interesting to see that that
these patterns actually kind of make
sense especially if we kind of
understand and even if ethiopians
understand themselves as being
you know kind of this extreme this
extreme of the world let's say and the
relationship to the rest of the world
you know
it seems to kind of fit together you
know yeah and i think you know even even
in this promise right
whether you're inside or outside
you know whether you're a a desert or a
wilderness you know it's it's like
the
uh was
the ability the capacity of the saints
uh and of their intercessions to go to
these really extreme places we're going
to talk about more in just a second um
but i think there's something
interesting about this too because one
of the things that you see in ethiopian
high geography is that
the the veneration of the snails is very
much a two-way street and what i mean by
this is there are all kinds of stories
about
you know so and so was a wealthy farmer
who decided to skip the commemoration of
this local saint because he had a plow
was field and so the saint shows up and
blights all of his crops
so
i mean this stuff this stuff i mean this
stuff it's tough man
that's tough story those are tough
stories giving you know john calvin just
the heebie-jeebies right now um
but i mean i mean that that's and you
actually find this thing in english high
geography too like this is very common
you know basically but but the idea is
that the the relationship between the
patron
and the person
is it's very much it's supposed to be a
two-way street but you and so it's easy
for people to dismiss it as a quid pro
quid pro
or like this kind of this transaction or
whatever but if you want to you can
understand it more generally yes even
secular people you can understand it in
a in a in a larger context by
understanding that if you don't
remember
your principalities if you don't
remember those things that bind you
together then yes you're going to be
cursed that is the if you don't remember
that which binds you then you're going
to fall apart then your world is going
to break down so if you want to destroy
a country destroy its heroes right
attack attack uh
you know attackers for columbus attack
george washington attack uh
uh all these you know all these figures
that are meant to be the
these pillars that hold society together
um if you stop to remember them and to
celebrate them then you're going to
actually see a blight on your crops or a
blight on your country so it's not it's
not just like a magical
uh transaction but it is an image of how
reality actually works as well
yes
yeah that's that's the thing i wanted to
key in on is that um there's a
uh
you you can you can even just imagine on
like the most boring and mundane level
right like
uh
what happens if you use
this analogy might come back to bite me
okay but like what happens if what
happens if you stop paying your taxes
right what happens if you if you just
stop doing the things that you need to
do
to
uh to exist in a in a civilized society
like what happens if you just decide
listen i'm not gonna
even very simple things like
uh keeping up your lawn so that your
neighbors don't hate your house every
time they look at it you know very basic
things like this like um
the and so stories like this what they
do is they extend that reality
um into the realm of the spiritual and
they say actually you know there's
there's
there's a there's a spiritual
neighborhood as well right that there
are these spiritual principalities and
that yeah if you don't if you don't
honor them i mean the thing is like if
if you live in uh an ancient or a
medieval society
and you decide i'm not going to let's
say you live in 14th century england you
say actually i'm not going to show up
for the corpus christi procession i'm
not going to go beat the bounds
right well what's that saying it's
saying i'm not part of this community
yeah right you're not just turning your
back on christ and on the saints but
you're actually also turning your back
on your neighbors
i'm saying is so it's so it's saying uh
is saying wealth
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna go plow my
field instead of instead of taking an
offering to the church
in memory of the saint right
um then that's going to be used to feed
the poor right so i'm i'm actually like
i'm i'm being greedy i'm hoarding i'm
refusing to to care for the poor i'm
refusing to venerate the same like all
of these things go together
and it's one of the weirdest things
about our society today i think that
that essentially the idea of care for
the poor yeah
and and then also the idea of veneration
have been completely
separated yeah i think it's one of the
things that's really destroyed
um our ability to to like
to do charity in a like a really
traditional and a christian way but you
can understand how
there's something frightening also about
a world that that that works that way
completely let's say if you think of of
uh because it can also in an excess like
if it goes too far it can create a world
of fear in a world of
you know you're constantly afraid that
if you don't do the right thing if
you're not you know if you're not
celebrating this thing or that thing
then you know your world is going to
collapse and so
i can understand also how sometimes it
can become too far and become almost
like
this rigid this kind of rigid system
that is impossible to without
flexibility yeah but i think it's also
important for us on the other extreme in
a world where basically
nothing matters and everybody just does
what they want and you know there are no
relationships between our us and our
neighbors uh that we we can understand
how the world works and how remembering
and celebrating the saints and the
things that bind it together is actually
a necessary part of of existence
yeah so that's that's why i'm trying to
point this out is is to say a couple of
things one is that these these three
patterns that we've just talked about
the the the sacred the holy theft
the uh the kidan um and then this idea
of of the sort of like
the saint as punisher right
um that all three of those things show
up
to some small degree
in
the hagiography of
let's say the calcidonian churches
um
but not to this degree
so what we're so this is a good example
of like where we see you know once we
get to ethiopia and we get to ethiopian
hag geography we see like the more
extreme patterns
manifesting themselves but also in a way
that
that does sort of serve as a container
yeah right yeah
so uh with that said last time we talked
a little bit about the nine saints yeah
um and the nine saints are these uh
they're also sometimes called like the
nine roman saints
or the nine righteous ones
uh and uh essentially this is a group of
saints um i think they're traditionally
supposed to all be from syria which is
of course part of the roman empire at
this time
uh but but i think
also like looking at the etymologies of
names and various other things
now people think some of them might have
come from syria some of them might have
come from as far away as rome like in
italy
so but essentially it's this group of
nine saints that come to
ethiopia within about a hundred years of
after the conversion of ethiopia
and uh and they come probably because of
the council of cal state on and
with the um they're they're they're
basically they they have to they're not
willing to adopt the uh they're not
willing to accept the the decrees of the
council so they have so they're
resisting they're resisting the the the
calcidon the calcidonian definition
right and they're looking for a place to
how can i say this to to contain their
knowledge or to contain their their
their experience right so these were
these were all monks they're all
scholars
um and they brought with them
quite a number of
texts and manuscripts which ended up not
surviving anywhere else for instance
there are additional clementine letters
i won't say clementine letters because
that means something else down here in
the south but
um
we have the song anyway
um but we have these like additional
clementine letters we have um actually a
number of texts that are like sort of
quasi new testament they're like kind of
part of the larger canon of the new
testament in ethiopia
and that that don't just don't survive
anywhere else and uh so the the
traditional belief is that these
manuscripts were brought by the nine
saints
uh with them um and they also did other
things like
translating a lot of liturgical texts
and uh a lot of actually
geography and other things into into
guess into the language of the ethiopian
people yeah so they're very very
important they're part of this you know
really in fact if you look up like any
just like top 10 list of ethiopian
saints of which there are i think at
least two on the internet
um there that they'll they'll feature
there in the timeline right it's sort of
like them and then after them um this
hypnographer named jared who's really
interesting because
uh he seems to have
uh at one point he left ethiopia because
of kind of a schism or a scandal
and he went to syria and while he was in
syria
um
you know he
came into contact with other you know
with with other forms of eastern
christianity and at some point he uh
composes this beautiful i mean really
beautiful acrostic poem to the mother of
god you can go out and look up the text
and i think saint vladimir seminary
press has a translation of it
but if you read through it it's got all
of these very similar
uh ideas and phrases that uh to those
that we find in the activist him to the
mother of god which is also an acrostic
so i think the two are
probably related um
but in any case
um so the nine saints uh they they're
responsible for
basically
they're they're more extreme
theologically as opposed to the rest of
the the church that say the imperial
church
but then they bring with them these they
bring with them the the these texts and
become this repository of knowledge and
so because it's the book of enoch
these are where we first discovered them
let's say uh i think was in the 19th
century 18th or 19th century this is
where they first reappeared on the
horizon people knew about them but then
all of a sudden here they are these
books yeah and it's a tricky question i
think as to whether
uh jubilees certainly seems to have been
preserved in ethiopia
because it was already a holy book of
the of the jewish community in ethiopia
before
before they converted to christianity
but
um but enoch and enoch and then also
just a bunch of other stuff i mean if
you just go up and you look up like the
uh
the the wikipedia page on the on the
ethiopian canon there will be there will
be books on there that you would have
never heard of before yeah like there's
some interesting but like was it the
book of adam and eve or whatever that
that that book is there's some really f
it's really interesting to read these
books because yeah and and like the
ascension of isaiah in some in some uh
yeah which is very important
christological text for some reasons
like things like that is it's a
it's
uh
it's it's just it's really interesting
it's really really interesting they
divide up proverbs differently
um
and they have you know some extra like i
said some extra clementine books they
also have you know like uh
some collections of apostolic cannons
and other stuff that's that's all sort
of part of their larger canon of the new
testament
um and that seems to date back to kind
of
this this infusion let's say
of the the more extreme pieces of
of learning and tradition in the
imperial church that then become
preserved in ethiopia yeah and that's
where again we keep coming back to this
image of ethiopia and not just having
the ark but acting as an ark in itself
as a nation and as a church uh being a
place where
things are preserved including some
extremes that have been kind of pruned
off in the in the imperial church let's
say
all right so uh
let's talk just a little bit about the
nine saints and a couple of their lives
because they're super interesting and
then we'll talk about some weirder stuff
yeah um
so
i'll just read a short little
commemoration here from their cynics our
room for um this is aragawi i hope i'm
saying that right
who's also surnamed
mikhail
of michael this holy man became a guide
to the servants of god on the road
um
and he went up again the guide to the
servants of god on the road so he's
supposed to be the leader
of these nine saints
and uh of course they're on the road
right um
you know not in a stable or fixed place
and then he comes to one it says he went
up to the holy dhabra damo this is a
very high mountain
holding the tail of a serpent yeah
and there he fought countless noble
fights
and god you have to see the images of
this they're dramatic because you see
them sometimes actually like coiled
up by the snake and being pulled up this
pillar you know this kind of high pillar
and so it actually looks like the snake
like not around the tree but there's
this verticality and then there's the
snake pulling up the saint up the up to
the up to the the
top of this pillar so so two days ago
three days ago from when we were
recording this was byzantine new year
and also the feast of saints in me and
the skylight and i posted that picture
in the symbolic world of this sort of
same image right where you have that the
serpent
coiled around the pillar and then sort
of like poised to strike and you have st
simeon there standing at the top of the
pillar and then that wonderful
you know open clam shell with it with a
pearl in it yeah
oyster oyster yeah with a pearl in it
um at the at the top um
which that's a wonderfully mysterious
image
yeah it's a very it's a very powerful
it's a very powerful image
and in this story also the snake kind of
carrying this saint up this ethiopian
saying up you can really see this whole
image of the bronze serpent and this
image of the idea of death turned
against death and how kind of asceticism
is also even that death turned against
death
and also also moses
moses taking the serpent by the tail
yeah so becoming a staff which is of
course the wrong way to grab a snake
but he takes the serpent by the by the
tail and then the serpent solidifies and
it becomes a staff it becomes a rod of
authority and uh of you know miracle
working
yeah what you have to do is fixing
change it's like so you have this
changing thing yes fix it if you grab it
if you're able to grab on to to uh to to
variability then you can transform it
into hierarchy and it becomes a it
becomes a staff
so that's the image that you see in this
you know also in both the image of saint
simian and the image of
and the image of this saint that gets
ascended up the cliff
yeah and i don't know there there's
we were talking about this a little bit
earlier but i think there is definitely
like a
a kind of more extreme person let's say
who
the only way forward for them the only
way for them to sort of ascend is to
take the serpent by the tail
um and
and there's there's like a there's a
paradox in that it's a dangerous it's an
inherently dangerous thing because
there's always this danger the serpent's
going to double back and bite you
um but the person who can do that
becomes he becomes a guide to the
servants of god on the road
and
yeah i don't know like this this
particular image has really been
i won't say bugging me but just really
stuck with me the last
the last several days yeah um so then
you've got
this is a weird one okay you've got uh
garema or isaac um
uh and uh he's he's a a roman prince
um
in fact in in this particular
hachiography it says his father was the
emperor of rome um and i don't know
yeah yeah pretty intense i i don't know
like like like historically which
emperor that is supposed to be it
doesn't say they had geography it's
probably not that important but yeah but
but uh he's a prince that's important
yes yeah uh so he's
he's a prince of rome
uh and he's a sort of a miraculous
conception his mother was barren she
prays to the mother of god
um she's given this son she names him
isaac
um and uh
and uh he's he he grows up
and uh he's he's made a deacon
and then he's made emperor
and then and you know again like it's a
little it's a little tricky to figure
out
is that supposed to be some historical
emperor seems like not right but
um but that it says that he sat and
judged justly and righteously for seven
years
and then saint abba pantaleon of the
cell this is another one of the nine
saints heard of him
and he said my son isaac let the dead
bury their dead come and seek the
kingdom of god so he he abandons his
his robes and his wealth and his power
and everything
and he
um
he leaves and becomes um
a monk
he leaves and becomes a monk so there's
uh and and it talks about
you know all of his different miracles
like one of the things that he seems to
do is be able to plant plants where they
shouldn't grow like he plants a grape
seed in you know
into a rock with this thumb and a grape
vine grows out
and and then
this is a weird story i'll just read
this bit to you it says one day certain
columnators
went to abba pentaleon so that's his
spiritual father and said the priest
isaac consecrated the offering after he
had eaten so he's being accused
of basically of not fasting before
liturgy right
um and ava pantaleon having gone to him
caught him on the road and he said to
him and these guys are always on the
road
said to him
wait man so that i may tell thee a
secret and saint isaac said to him let
men shut me in
and remove the stones from us
and they turned aside for his distance
of five stadia and abba pantaleon said
unto him oh my son isaac thou has
terrified me and thereupon he was called
abba garima and having finished his good
course a redeemer appeared to him and
promised him etc right
so
i don't even think i understand it's
really hard to follow okay but what it
seems to be and somebody you know write
in and correct me on this
uh but what seems to have happened is
that he is accused
of
a sin a scandal
and rather than defending himself
he requests
to be shut up
like to be like walled in right
and then and
and then that's
that's it
like
whoa yeah so basically he lives he just
ends up living like in a little waldo
cell for the rest of his life but that's
how he becomes the same basically right
and that this is this is
and you know
it does not say whether or not he really
did this right now it does say that he
was a great faster that his flesh
cleaved to his bones and all the stuff
so it seems unlikely yeah he really did
this but he doesn't defend himself
and it definitely seems like pantaleon
his his uh spiritual father you know
that he's
um scandalized you know and wants to you
know like doesn't tell him
why he wants to talk to him he's like
hey come here i'm gonna i'm gonna talk
to you about something tell you let me
tell you a secret
and and so then his his solution to
handling this this is to basically make
himself the secret it's too
to wall himself off so i mean this is
some of the stuff like you read this
stuff and it's like man
there's something really important here
and i'm not sure i know what it is
yeah yeah
so and then pantaleon i'll just mention
him quickly uh he was called pantaleon
of the cell and the reason for this
is that
um
he
he goes to the top of a mountain
and he cuts himself a cell out of the
rock and the cell is five cubits long
three cubits wide so
not very wide and then three cubits deep
um and so it's it's all a single stone
no door when opening and if you work out
the dimensions basically the point of
the cell
is that it's a cell in which you can
only stand you can never sit or lie down
yeah
so he's like sort of protected from the
elements but he's very much like kind of
a skylight you know yeah where he's just
like and basically that's where that's
where he is
um and um he
he blesses
uh one particular ethiopian king caleb
who has a war with a local actually
jewish king
and um
and uh
so that's that's kind of his story so
those are the three of the nine saints
that we have like the most detailed
lives about at least in the synaxarium
that i could find now i think that if
you
i'm sure there are some ethiopian people
out there who know more stories i'm
obviously there's some of the images i
forget which name of the nine saints are
but that when you see the actual images
they're very extreme the iconography
itself is extreme so i remember in
ethiopia one of the images of
these nine saints was the saint that in
imitation of christ had thrown himself
from a cliff
and had died on these pointy rocks and
so you actually see an icon of this
saint being trans trans transpires by
these pointy rocks at the bottom of uh
of a cliff
and uh and there's another one of them
who has wings like uh like a seraphim
and has these like nine wings uh around
him um so it's like when you see these
saints in the church it's just like all
these saints next to each other and you
have this image of a sand being brought
up by a snake there's another one who
fed of dying birds by his tears and so
you can see him holding a bird with its
beak in his eye so you see all these ex
so when you go into the church you don't
even know who these saints are but you
can know that they're part of these the
nine saints and you see all their images
next to each other and all of them are
engaging in very kind of extreme
iconography
you do get this sense of
really like a magical fantastical uh
world
one of the one of the images that really
struck me the most like in some of these
underground churches that exist
there's one church which is dedicated to
saint mercurious
and so you go into the church and then
there's this icon of saint mercurius on
a horse and next to him there are these
two dog-headed men right and uh and it's
the legend that these two dog-headed men
had killed mercurius's father
and mercurius ended up converting them
and then they become like his companions
but also these fierce warriors that can
be kind of turn against the pagans when
you need to uh you know and so so you
can see these extreme images all over
the place yeah the saint bartholomew
uh the apostle bartholomew in the
ethiopian hagiography um
uh
has a
like a legion of cannibal
sinocephalites right cannibal dog faces
that's that's how they're translated in
this english translation the the dog
faces
um which obviously like if you're just
like sort of scanning a page like
dog face is going to jump out at you
uh but but he has like he has uh he has
these you know this legion of cannibal
dog faces that that sort of like
uh that he converts and then like you
know other people try to try to kill him
or try to do him harm the dog faces
actually turn
and defend him become guard dogs yeah
they become yeah they become guard dogs
like it's it's exactly the symbolism of
a dog right you can have a wolf or you
can have a guard dog right um and that's
what they that's what they become yeah
and you see this yeah it's basically the
same as saint mercurius it's just that
and it can help you then understand
these images of the dog-headed uh saint
christopher as being a soldier like
these soldier images of the dog-headed
saint christopher also when you
understand the other legends of of
xenocephaly that existed
uh in the world you you you can kind of
see why these images kind of glue come
together and and manifest it the way
they do
yeah i'll just read this a little bit
here
um
after this our lord jesus christ
commanded him that it's bartholomew to
go to the city of barbar that is the
city of the barbarians nice the city of
barbara right well yeah bar bar is yeah
yeah yeah right because
that's what that's what non-greek
speakers sound like to greek speakers
um and he sent him to uh with andrew the
apostle and by the way say andrew has
lots of encounters with dog-faced men in
um
basically every uh
geographical tradition it's definitely
there in like the anglo-saxon uh uh
there's a there's a poem about it yeah
the story of abominable like abominable
who then becomes christian it's a that's
a beautiful little story about the dog
so he goes to the city of barbara and he
sent him to him andrew the apostle uh
with his helper to help him and the
people of that city were exceedingly
wicked and they would not receive the
apostles who were working before them
signs and wonders and god commanded one
of the dog-faced cannibals
so they're cannibals as well to submit
to the apostles and not to resist them
in anything which they ordered him to do
and they took him with him to that city
and the men of that city brought out
wild beasts against the apostles to eat
them up and straight away that dog face
rose up against those wild beasts and
rent them asunder and also slew a great
many men of that city and of course
everyone in the city converts it's this
stuff is gnarly man this stuff is really
uh it's really incredible yeah but in
terms of understanding kind of the
symbolism of the barbarian and the
symbolism of right it's like it's the
same symbolism that the emperor the
byzantine emperor used in taking the
viringian guard around him you know like
having a foreign guard around you that
is
only uh you know is only submitting to
you
uh and using this kind of foreign power
as a way to defend yourself uh against
the foreigner like it's the same as the
as the french king giving normandy to
the to the scandinavians so that they
would have this inner
these inner barbarians that would act as
guards for the outside and so but it's
just a more fairy tale or more kind of
mythological telling of this pattern
which is a real pattern in the world
that you that is important to uh to
understand
yeah
so i i think that uh
i think
so there are there are a lot of
cannibals actually as it turns out
here in uh
yes in ethiopia the ethiopian tradition
and the craziest story this is the
craziest story is the story of a
bellai the cannibal
and this is one of the things when i
went to ethiopia marked me the most
because
the iconography of the light of cannibal
is often on one set of the doors which
moves into the sanctuary which moves
into the holy place
and so with the story is that there's a
man
who received guests very similar to how
abraham received these three guests
these three angels but instead of giving
the angels food instead of feeding the
stranger he receives food from the
stranger so he actually eats the
stranger's food and it turns out that
these three
guests are demons and what they're
giving him to eat is human flesh
and so in when he eats the human flesh
he becomes obsessed now with eating
human flesh and then goes out and starts
to like eat
eat people and just kind of becomes a
crazy cannibal eating human people uh
until one day he's wandering through the
desert and he sees a an ascetic who
who is kind of there in the desert and
asked the lie for a glass of water in
the name of the holy virgin
and bellai gives him water
and then continues on his life
and then when billy the cannibal dies he
comes to the judgment of christ
and as he is being judged and going to
be sent to hell
the mother of god comes and tips the
scale
to his side because one day he gave a
glass of water a couple of water in my
name yeah exactly and so there's still
and so what's crazy is that the image
that you see on the door to the
sanctuary which you have to remember is
where communion is coming from so the
body and flesh of christ is coming out
of the sanctuary but on one of the doors
of the sanctuary you have this image of
a of a man sitting eating pieces of
human flesh um so it's like this extreme
manifestation of one aspect of the
scandalous aspect of communion being
represented but then if you look at the
story completely it's also a testimony
to the universality of
of salvation and just how far the
salvation of christ is able to reach
even beyond our our own judgment and on
our own understanding of what is
possible you know in in the name of god
so it actually shows two extremes one is
the extreme scandal of communion the
extreme scandal of the most abhorrent
behavior of cannibalism and the extreme
of
of a man who is completely lost and
saved for a very small gesture uh done
you know in in the name of the virgin so
it's it actually is just we talk about
this manifestation of extremes it's hard
to go any further than that yeah there's
there there definitely
should be something
scandalous about salvation
and i i think that when when it stops
being just like when the cross stops
being a little bit scandalous to us then
we've sort of forgotten what it was
about right yeah
um
and it's interesting because in in
western christianity in particular uh
you know you go and read like scholastic
authors i mean aquinas is a whole long
discourse about
why is the eucharist not cannibalism
right and so he really wants to distance
probably rightly so
right he wants to distance
uh
like the two things yeah but then also
also like in the ethiopian tradition
like also i think probably rightly so
like there's there's
there's a a willingness to a willingness
to not like shirk away
um because i mean it was a scandalous
thing when christ told told it to the
jews you know tell people hey do you
want to be my disciple if you want to
live with me and and have my life you
just all you have to do you have to eat
my body and drink my blood yeah that
text is saying john when you realize
that he's actually just talking out in
the public it's so crazy yeah and he
keeps using you know like this word that
specifically means chewing like you
gotta
you know
and and like uh and he's just saying
these things to people and and
you know and they're like well this is a
hard saying you know like i
i feel like i feel like if if the way
that you're describing communion like is
not a hard saying then then you're
you're missing something right and so so
yeah this is a um
this is uh i think i think that's maybe
like the ultimate example like to put
that on the holy doors
like i can't you know i can't imagine
right uh
we had this we have this um
uh father fodia savant uh who i think
sometimes watches these videos so yeah
if you do hey father podius
we love you yeah um uh he he uh had this
new iconostas uh
carved for his church here in allen
it's beautiful it's one of the most
beautiful iconistas uh that i've ever
seen
and on the on the holy doors there are a
couple of you know they could be sort of
dragons or cockatrices you know
um on top of the holy doors sort of
guarding the entrance to the sanctuary
made instant intuitive sense to me i was
like that is awesome that's medieval i'd
love it i've had so many people
um so did you did you see the pictures
of
father fodius's new economy like i
helped unload it dude and he's like and
and they're like they're like um yeah um
um i'm just i'm just not sure about like
the the monsters on the doors like
what's that about you know so like even
that little bit
like
we know that we know that it's not like
your bishop has a staff with two snakes
right oh
why are you so bothered by that i get
that question so much and i always just
send them your article and then they
read it and they're like oh that's
really cool okay good to know and then
it's all good but but that's that so
that's the you know but the thing is
like we know because it's in the church
because we're used to the idea that
everything like within the church
especially in the sanctuary has this
deep symbolic resonance
like we know that it's not uh well it's
not arbitrary right it's like it's it
doesn't it's not neutral
so then you have to ask the question
what it's doing so i explained you know
well it's the the idea of the guardian
right like that this is what a cherub is
right
is a monster who by the way the the four
the four beasts the cherubs have their
own feast day
in the ethiopian church
and they have their it's got its own
entry in the san xarian
and uh it's super cool super super great
that's awesome yeah so um
i couldn't tell you what day it is
because i don't
i don't know the ethiopian calendar it's
they have different months and stuff but
but uh but it's it's really cool um and
so you know like you start to explain
like okay but in the bible god's throne
is guarded by monsters like we're used
to thinking angels these are nice that
you know but like
yeah well god rides the cherub across
the river right and it's it's like it
looks pretty much like a bull with wings
you know with like it doesn't it seems
like it's more of a
something you mount you know so yeah so
that said i don't think father fordius
could get away with a cannibal
on the on the holy doors yes yeah that
would be a little much that would be a
little much
you know although
you say that but although there is a
tradition of putting the good thief on
the uh on the the northern door of the
you know of the of the entrance into the
sanctuary which is not as scandalous but
it shows us the scandal very similar to
the scandal of bellai which is this like
this like one moment of contrition that
the right that the the good thief has
and who makes him makes him the first in
paradise basically right so we have
these these verses in uh uh holy week in
the orthodox church where we sing about
the good thief stealing paradise and in
in some eastern churches not in not in
the orthodox eastern orthodox church but
in some eastern traditions i think this
might be like a syrian thing
um but there's actually on holy friday
they actually have a liturgical tug of
war
between like one of the deacons and one
of the priests what where where yeah
would they have like this pole or like
spear
and they they do like a like a
ritualized tug of war
at the you know right on the on the on
the the entrance to the sanctuary and
this is the it's basically it's like the
the guarding cherub trying to keep the
thief out of paradise
and the good thief stealing his way in
that's amazing
so that there's that that kind of stuff
is there man and and it's it's
interesting because like in the orthodox
church on on and i know this isn't quite
ethiopia but it's still relevant uh on
on like sundays uh the verses that we
sing the sticker of verses that we sing
with beatitudes if your church does the
beatitudes uh they're all about the good
thief right and so it's funny because
you'll you'll you know like talking to
our evangelical friends love you guys
there's somebody's there's always going
to be somebody who's like okay but why
do i need to do all this stuff because
the good thief dot dot like that somehow
like proves their point and
and
and and you know like oh well no one no
one has ever thought of the good thief
before you know but actually if you look
at eastern liturgy especially holy week
is one of the most important
stories for us because the you know
there's a bunch of things going on there
right that the the the love and the
clemency of god right um
but also like this hope
you know like the
you know that prayer that we say you
know i will not you know speak of your
mystery i want to give you a kisses to
judas i will not speak of your ministry
mysteries to your enemies but like the
thief will i confess thee remember me o
lord in thy kingdom so it's to basically
say
god i don't really have anything to
bring to the table at the end of the day
but if if he could get in
then maybe you'll also have mercy on me
right and uh and so there there is
there is that embrace of a scandal
that's at the heart of
the heart of our salvation yeah um which
is really beautiful so for me one of the
other things i wanted to bring about to
kind of balance out our discussion was
to to maybe help people understand also
the way in which the ark
kind of participates in the structure of
the ethiopian liturgy because now we
talked about the extreme the extremes in
the sense of really the extremes right
of these fringe behaviors and these kind
of fringe moments of sanctity that
exists a little bit in in the orthodox
tradition but seem to kind of fill up
you know the different ethiopian
traditions but then you also have the
idea of containing which we talked about
in terms of the holy text but we also
understand the ark
is present in the liturgical life of the
the ethiopians through what's called the
tabot and so the ark of the covenant is
in this chapel uh you know in aksum but
there are replicas they're symbolic
replicas they're not like actual
replicas but they're symbolic replicas
of the ark which are present in every
single church in ethiopia there are very
few people supposedly at least this is
what i was told by an ethiopian man that
there are very few people that make
these that it's a very kind of
it's a very tight group of people that
have the capacity to make these these
image these uh these these little
they're like wooden boxes um not boxes
like wooden blocks that represent the
tablets really more than the arc in the
sense of
even that name
yeah they they represent the tablets
basically of of the of the law
and they're placed in the altar area of
the church like in the altar uh or under
the altar like in the in the um the
table let's say um and so you can on you
can see how this
idea of the container of the sacred kind
of just reaches all the way down into
the everyday life of all the churches
and what's fascinating about a lot of
these tabot is that they're icons
actually that they're they're they're
relief icons of of of christ on the
cross or different
they're not always sometimes there's
some text on it or sometimes there's
actually abstract symbols on these on
these
but often there are they are they are
icons and so the image becomes also this
kind of container for for the sacred uh
so it's it's just important to see how
just permeating all through
the imagery of ethiopian uh
christianity there are these elements of
the extreme edge as both extreme and as
container for everything and that's why
i always go back to the
the image of the nest which i like
because the nest is a
container that's made out of remnants
you know like you know there's little
bits of
string and fur and twigs and whatever
birds can find like and then it's but
but then it's brought together into this
this place it can actually shelter and
protect something and by the way that
that symbolism of having like the little
the little replica of the ark or the
tables
of the law
in your sanctuary
is the same thing
that we do in the orthodox church when
we put the mother of god in the apes
over the altar
uh like symbolically it's a very similar
function right the understanding that
she is she is the new arc she is the
she's the um
the warm mercy seat right was one of the
phrases that's used of her right so the
idea is that she's the
yeah the seed of wisdom the mercy seat
all these types of images of the mother
as the container as the the resting
place of
of of the presence of god in the in the
church
um and so then so then maybe just to
like my last comment on this you might
want to finish with something else but
is to remind people of also this what
started our discussion on ethiopia was
an eschatological vision that was
present
that that's present in the apocalypse of
of of pseudomethodius which is this idea
of the roman emperor
you know joining with the edge or
joining with the end and coming out in
the end out of this edge and so you have
this idea of the beginning and the end
which is manifested in the story of the
nine saints as well that is you have
these roman saints that seem to come
from all over the roman empire
who go into ethiopia to find an ark and
to find a place where christianity is
preserved and where you know
to act as this kind of last
resting place for all these traditions
and so in their tradition they have this
image of the roman coming towards
ethiopia and then in our tradition we
have the same vision in a different form
but of the roman emperor in the moment
of crisis hiding in ethiopia so that in
the end ethiopia will stretch its hands
out unto god and the last emperor will
rise out of ethiopia and kind of
manifest this last glorious moment
before the end of the world yeah
the thing i would say to cap this out is
is also to remind people why are we
looking at
why have we spent you know this is was
this
ethiopia three or four i can't even
remember now i was about like three i've
just been living with it like i have a
stack of books and stuff like i've just
been living with it for a while now so i
really have no idea how much of this
we've done but
the reason we've done so much in
ethiopia is for two two reasons i think
one is
um because it's a
it's a great
proof case
like it's a gate a great case study
that's the way to say it it's a great
case study
for showing
how the stories that people tell about
themselves how the saints that they
venerate and how even like the sort of
dark or ambiguous parts of our histories
right that that all of these sort of
contain the meaning
um and they contain the the the identity
and the framework that that people uses
to engage with the world which is really
what universal history is about
so we are gonna you know er people keep
asking like okay but what are what are
you gonna do
you know like this or this or this you
know uh the reason we've been doing
ethiopia is because you know a lot of
people don't know about it so they don't
know all the cool symbolism
but also because because it's what you
know
if if i'm if i'm gonna sit here and talk
about you know what's the symbolism of
america which is the one we get asked
for the most like in those comments like
people just you know and i've hinted at
it maybe one of these days we'll do it
but
the
the the problem with trying to do the
symbolism of america is that um
is that because we think we all think we
know it so well
right and our audience is primarily
you know americans right we think we
know it so well there's always going to
be there's there's there's a uh we're
just not as attentive to the weirdness
um or the the you know the these
traditional shapes and structures that
are
still met that are they're still
manifesting themselves today again like
rubbing lincoln's nose for a blessing
you know that's something i've done as a
child right
um i didn't think anything about it at
the time because everyone was like like
and that's the thing like when you're
participating in like a cult of
veneration most of the time you're not
doing it as a conscious thing like most
of the time like this is just you know
like you go to a concert and you get
really amped you know because everyone
else around you is also really amped and
it's just it feels like a natural way to
be
so
um
so by by going somewhere that's like a
little a little bit different
it allows us to sort of like look at
these patterns with fresh eyes and so
then maybe when we we turn our gaze to
parts of universal history that are
going to be a little more familiar to us
we'll be the pump will be sort of primed
and we'll be sort of ready to to start
thinking in these ways yeah and i think
also looking at at an extreme version or
looking at kind of the the edge of the
universal history in terms of
christianity
um
you know can also
how can i say this it can also help us
say how see like i said how these
stories cross over and how
even like
the way that people talk about
themselves
often even though the stories are
different and the way that it's
presented is slightly different ends up
strangely connecting with the way that
other people tell stories about about
those same people and so there is a way
in which we can kind of look through the
idiosyncrasy and see that there is a
pattern that there are patterns of
identity by which we recognize each
other as kind of all participating in
this grand in this grand narrative so
so we've talked i guess for three videos
now kind of with an outsider perspective
on some of the stuff and i know it's
your goal to hopefully
get uh
uh some uh clergymen from the ethiopian
orthodox church on the channel and so
i'm really hoping i if they're i mean if
there are people out there that you know
that you know the bishops or priests or
deacons you know and you would be
willing to talk about ethiopian
tradition from an insider perspective
i'd be very happy to hear from you and
i'll be trying to at least have one
conversation with someone from inside
the the ethiopian tradition to kind of
explore it from the inside let's say
yeah we'll see if we work that out so
yeah yeah
um
thanks jonathan this has been a ton of
fun and
you know i guess uh people want to keep
hearing universal history i definitely
have more things to talk about so that's
great i'm excited there's so much i mean
there's so much to talk about that we
could just we could we'll just keep
going yeah as long as people are paying
attention are excited about this we'll
we'll continue so everybody thank you
for your attention don't forget to check
out rich all of richard's projects like
amon sewell uh and uh what about what's
happening with this book that you
mentioned a few episodes so finding the
golden key it's gonna be an essay
collection on this recovering
sacramental imagination i'm still hoping
you're gonna going to contribute we've
gotten i would say about 14 submissions
ish so far um and a lot of them are
pretty great there's definitely one
that was written by somebody dropping
some acid so you know who you are um
whoever that is i don't know it's uh
it's wonderful it was like oh i'm gonna
just save this because this is it was
just like this long crazy stream of
consciousness but other than that we've
gotten some really great
submissions so i want to um
i still want to hear from more symbolic
world people
so if you go to findingthegoldenkey.com
you can submit an abstract uh for a
paper and there's there's an outline of
the kinds of things we're looking for
um if you don't hear back immediately do
not panic you have not been rejected
but the deadline is through the end of
this year so you still have about as of
this recording about three months to
get the abstract together and then
you'll have time after that to write the
full essay so um do that um in
i don't know if it'll already be in the
past by the time this video comes out
but if not um here uh the
uh
middle of september the 11th and 12th i
think i'm going to be at uh father
andrew stephen damien's church
in emmaus pennsylvania great um and i
will be there doing doc smoot live we're
going to be talking about tolkien and
more tolkien and saint maximus so
please come to that if you're in the
pennsylvania area and then in october
middle of october i always i never have
the dates for these things in my head
because i'm just really bad at
you know calendars but put it in the
description you can put it in the
description
yeah in october in october there's gonna
be a uh an event in wichita kansas which
is uh the the which is fourth rome um
and we'll be um
uh there's gonna be an event in wichita
kansas at the eighth day institute and i
will actually be talking about
the celtic sacramental imagination and
the holy grail and i'm gonna be giving
like two talks on that so if you're one
of the people in the comments who's like
okay but do ireland next do ireland next
like go to which duh come to wichita and
you can hear all about it you can also
hear all about the holy grail uh which
is basically
i've had this crazy idea that i've been
working on for three or four years now
and i'm gonna actually try to actually
tell people about it in person
in wichita so come come and hear that so
all right that sounds great so richard
thanks again for your time and your
energy and uh yeah i'm still as excited
as i was in our first episode so let's
keep going yeah this is great stuff
thanks jonathan all right bye